[Musik]
es gibt ja vielen bürgerinnen und
bürgern sowie mir irgendwie haben wir
nach all diesen langen zwei jahren vor
jahren auch mal
verdient das ist irgendwie wieder besser
wird und es sieht ein bisschen danach
aus dass wir genau das auch vor uns
haben sie sind seit zwei jahren jetzt in
dem
drama so drin und irgendwie muss das
auch mal langsam vorbei sein ich würde
mich auf jeden fall freuen wenn die
clubs und bars wieder aufmachen und man
einfach wieder
gut tanzen könnte und einfach auch
wieder ja etwas ungeplante in die stadt
gehen könnte lässig oder maßnahmen
gelockert werden sollen ist
grundsätzlich gut ins drehen so viele
leute durch da wir selber inhaber von
geschäften sind freue ich mich wenn die
kunden einfach mal wieder völlig
unbedacht und ohne maske bei uns in die
geschäfte kommen kann ich finde die
masken pflicht sollte im öffentlichen
raum bzw
dort wo leute auf engem raum
zusammenkommen durchaus noch eine weile
erhalten bleiben weil das das
effizienteste mittel ist es im moment
gibt gegen infektionen
schirm guten abend herzlich willkommen
zu diesem zdf spezial die nachfolgenden
sendungen verschieben sich um gute zehn
minuten denn die nehmen wir uns jetzt um
zu klären wie sich durch die beschlüsse
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von
heute ganz konkret ihr leben ändert denn
jetzt ist klar es gibt ihn und zwar ab
sofort den ersten schritt zurück in die
normalität sofern sie geimpft oder
genesen sind dürfen sie jetzt wieder mit
zu vielen menschen privat treffen wie
sie wollen und der zweite schritt der
volk zugleich in gut zwei wochen am
vierten märz dann dürfen zum beispiel
auch wieder ungeimpfte wenn sie getestet
sind in cafés restaurants und hotels der
dritte schritt und letzte dann in einem
guten monat 20 märz alle dürfen wieder
fast alles
die einen atmen durch endlich auf ende
in sicht die anderen machen sich sorgen
ist das zu früh zu schnell kann das gut
gehen und zum zweiten team team vorsicht
gehört auch er bundesgesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach mit dem wir gleich
sprechen vorher zeigt aber noch britta
buchholz welche fragen lauterbachs
corona politik aufwirft
mit ihm als obersten krisenmanager waren
viele hoffnungen verbunden karl
lauterbach viele meinten endlich einer
vom fach doch ausgerechnet unter ihm
passieren taktische fehler beispiel
fehler nummer eins die kommunikation
während sich die bevölkerung nach
positiven aussichten sind errechnet karl
lauterbach pessimistische szenarien zur
prophezeit der deutschland bis zu 500
corona tote pro tag wenn das land nach
dem vorbild israels öffnen sollte angst
minister nannte ihn daraufhin die
oppositionelle cdu erst vor einer woche
mahnt er können also breite lockerungen
wie sie derzeit diskutiert werden zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht vertreten nicht
wundere mich über die diskussion die zum
teil in der politik jetzt zu beobachten
ist nun will auch er locker mit augenmaß
fehler nummer zwei der genesenden status
das robert koch institut unter lothar
wieler verkürzte über nacht den
genesenen status von sechs auf drei
monate der behördenchef in der kritik
lauterbach verteidigt ihn erst heute
entmachtete er ihn jetzt wieder selbst
über den genesenen status entscheiden
und ihn sogleich wieder erhöhen ein
zickzackkurs
fehler nummer drei die impfpflicht für
sein ziel liegt der minister selbst hand
an die impfquote hoch bringen doch nun
lassen sich kaum noch weitere deutsche
impfen der ausweg die impfpflicht doch
wenn sie kommen sollte dann wohl erst
wenn schon wieder gelockert wird auch
bayerns krisenmanager gibt sich
skeptisch
kanzler bundesgesundheitsminister wollen
eine impfpflicht das zu begrüßen aber
sie tun nichts dafür dass das problem
und das kritisieren die probleme sind
vielschichtig einerseits sind die
instanzen weiter besorgniserregend hoch
andererseits beschließen bund und länder
lockerungen der oberste krisenmanager
lauterbach steht ziemlich unter druck
ja und jetzt live für ein gespräch mit
uns bereit schönen guten abend herr
lauterbach seien sie heute setzen sich
dafür ein das stück für stück gelockert
wird dabei haben sie vor gut einer woche
noch gewarnt wenn jetzt gelockert wird
kann es 400 bis 500 tote pro tag geben
wie passt das zusammen erstmal guten
abend
es gibt da keinen widerspruch wenn wir
jetzt alle
maßnahmen wegnehmen würden das würde auf
einen schlag komplett gelockert dann
sollen die fallzahlen wieder stark
steigen und dann würden wir instanzen
erwarten können die deutlich höher sind
als die die wir jetzt haben und dann
hätte man noch mehr tote das geben die
modelle her mit denen wir gearbeitet
haben aber ich will es mal so sagen also
wir haben doch tatsächlich jetzt in den
letzten monaten zuerst die del-tabelle
und dann die omikron werde das haben wir
doch gut gemeistert wir sind doch mit
weniger
fällen und auch sind wie viel weniger
todesfällen durch diese also bällen
gekommen wie einige unserer
nachbarländer und wenn der erfolg da ist
und man muss man doch den erfolg im
vordergrund sehen und ich als minister
muss immer darauf hinweisen wenn wir ihn
vorsichtig sind dann steigt die zahl der
opfer die wir vermeiden können darum
habe ich hingewiesen und das kein
widerspruch
und auch die lockerung die wir jetzt
machen sind erstmal maßvoll und kommen
in schritten und somit ist das aus
meiner sicht schon also die richtige
vorgehensweise
sie immer wieder gesagt wir haben im
vergleich zu anderen ländern viele
ältere ungeimpfte und für diese große
gruppe älterer ungeimpfte haben wir eine
gute bilanz vorzuweisen viel weniger
todesfälle als zu befürchten gewesen war
die die öffnung soll in zwei schritten
kommen doch wenn man sich auf etwas
verlassen kann dann doch darauf dass
gerade nicht alle länder auch das
umsetzen was bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beschlossen
wird und auch dieses mal hat der
überbietungswettbewerb wer öffnet am
schnellsten ja längst begonnen was
wollen sie dagegen tun und dafür sorgen
dass es gerade nicht dazu kommen dass es
wieder aus dem ruder läuft was kann man
da tun ich kann nur an die länder
appellieren und kann daraufhin war sind
werden wir jetzt unverhältnismäßig
locker dann werden wir einen rückfall
erleiden und das versuche ich halt zu
verhindern aber man muss also immer
ehrlich sein und zur ehrlichkeit gehört
dazu bisher ist es uns gelungen
maßvoll vorzugehen wenn wir das nicht
schaffen dann erleiden wir einen
rückfall ich glaube dass wir das alle
verhindern wollen und da ich glaube
daher dass die ministerpräsidenten sich
an die regeln die wir heute beschlossen
haben auch halten werden im beschluss
betonen sie heute zitat die
notwendigkeit sämtliche anstrengungen zu
unternehmen um die folgen der pandemie
für kinder und jugendliche ab zu bildern
konkreter wird es dann nicht ab wann
gibt es denn auch für kinder wieder
echte normalität wand fallen zum
beispiel masken im klassenzimmer das
hängt von der inzidenz ab gott sei dank
ist er die institute auch bei den
kindern nicht ganz so hoch wie wir
zuerst befürchtet hatten da ist es auch
gelungen insbesondere durch die masken
pflicht viel zu erreichen die omikron
variante lässt sich durch masken tragen
recht gut beherrschen und das hat ist
dass sich in den schulen auch gelungen
aber es hängt einfach alles davon ab wie
gut bekommen die die fallzahlen runter
vor ungefähr einem monat hatte ich schon
vorher gesagt dass wir ungefähr mitte
februar den höhepunkt der fallzahlen mit
micon erwarten können das ist genauso
eingetreten mit dem modell des
robert-koch-instituts berechnet von der
neue unter portmann und wenn es jetzt
systematisch weiter runter geht dann
sind in einigen wochen auch die schulen
massiv zu entlasten
heute auch beschlossen sie entscheiden
wieder wie lange der genesen geimpfte
status gilt und nicht mehr das rk ii
entziehen sie damit dem rk ii und seinem
chef herrn wieder das vertrauen der
wähler hat das vertrauen das ich in zehn
jahren vertrauen es hat sich
herausgestellt dass also das rk ii sehr
gut die wissenschaftliche basis für
solche beschlüsse bringen kann aber dass
es dann doch eine politische frage ist
wie werden diese beschlüsse kommuniziert
werden sie durch gesetzlich werden sie
mit den ländern abgestimmt das sind dann
ja doch im großen und ganzen echte
politische beschlüsse von daher also
habe ich darum gebeten das war meine
eigene rolle wieder etwas gestärkt wird
ich möchte auch die länder stärker
einbringen das ist keine schwächung des
robert-koch-instituts denn die
wissenschaftliche basis die wird ja
weiterhin vom robert koch institut
erarbeitet und das macht das
robert-koch-institut auch sehr gut
sondern eine stärkung des
gesundheitsminister herr lauterbach
vielen dank für die ausführung heute
ja das impfen sollte immer der weg raus
aus der pandemie seien und jetzt zeigt
sich dass auch ohne deutliche steigerung
der importe zumindest die mikrowelle
vorerst gebrochen scheint zahlen daten
und fakten dazu hat simone müller
die deutschen freuen sich auf einen
möglichen freedom day und das trotz der
hohen zahl an neuinfektionen in den
letzten sieben tagen waren das im
schnitt 182 1800 pro tag wobei die
höchstzahl der scheitelpunkt wurde am 11
februar überwunden wurde was dabei
positiv stimmt ist die hospitalisierung
rate zurzeit müssen laut
robert-koch-institut sechs menschen pro
100.000 einwohner wegen corona im
krankenhaus behandelt werden
und auch die zahl der kurve patienten
die intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
müssen stagniert weitestgehend heute
waren es
2467 patienten
was könnte ein wegfall aller corona
regeln bedeuten in unserem nachbarland
dänemark gab es das bereits anfang
februar
bisher stieg die sieben tage incidents
nur geringfügig von damals bereits über
5.000 auf heute
5369 fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
alarmierend ist allerdings die zahl der
toten 3,7 von 100.000 einwohnern sterben
derzeit in dänemark an corona deutsch
nicht mehr als im vergleich zu
deutschland mit rund 1,5 toten pro
100.000 einwohner in den letzten sieben
tagen
das kommt durch die geplanten
lockerungen da auf uns zu schauen wir in
die zukunft und zwar mit einem der sie
berechnen kann thorsten der professor
für klinische pharmazie guten abend herr
lehrer sagen sie sie haben auf der
grundlage der heute beschlossenen
schrittweisen lockerung berechnet wie
sich dadurch das infektionsgeschehen
verändert was zeigen ihren zahlen droht
uns eine ähnliche situation wie aktuell
in dänemark
ja also was wir sehen ist also dass
durch die schrittweise lockerungen
dürften sich die inzidenz also zunächst
auch mal auf einem sehr hohen niveau
wirklich verharren bevor sie dann durch
den wegfall der maßnahmen ende märz und
noch mal deutlich steigen können das
bedeutet auf den intensivstationen
eigentlich dass dieser anstieg
wahrscheinlich zu mindestens sein wird
aber wir müssen ähnlich wie in dänemark
auch mit einem deutlichen anstieg der
täglichen toten rechnen bis zu 400 fälle
pro tag sagt unser modell vorher das ist
ein deutlicher preis der für mehr
freiheit sehr wahrscheinlich gezahlt
werden muss was heißt das denn für das
ende der mikrowelle gibson ostern ohne
omikron und ohne einschränkungen ja
wieso ist das schon mal noch mal sehr
lange hin und omikron dürfte bis dahin
auf keinen fall überwunden haben ob es
zu einschränkungen kommt das wird sehr
stark davon abhängen wie wir uns
verhalten wie wir die eigenverantwortung
der bürgerinnen und bürger stärken und
wie wir mit der impfung weitergehen das
wird also ganz wichtig sein da ist
wirklich voranzutreiben und dann sehen
wir wo wir an ostern stehen werden die
grafik wurde gerade eingeblendet könnten
können sie uns sagen zwischen also was
worst case best case sein kann
naja der worst case der variiert
natürlich sehr stark es gibt gewisse
unsicherheiten einfach in diesen in
diesen in diesen produktionen das muss
man einfach bedenken weil vor allem das
verhalten der menschen die so stark
predigt ihr bar ist es gibt große
schwankungen wie das aufgenommen wird
und von daher glaube ich haben wir hier
einfach eine große bandbreite von dem
was ja auch zu erwarten haben die
bandbreite ist groß und der blick noch
mal weiter weg im herbst was steht da zu
befürchten neue variante die wir noch
gar nicht kennen und
worauf müssen wir uns einstellen naja
bis zum herbst es noch lange hin das ist
sehr schwierig dort wirklich genau
vorsagen zusagen zu machen aber
eigentlich davon ausgehen dass wir auch
im herbst wieder mit einer neuen welle
rechnen müssen das ausmaß der welle
hängt natürlich sehr stark davon ab
welche variante vorherrscht das wird uns
die biologie zeigen und natürlich auch
die impfquote wird eine rolle spielen
deswegen wird es wichtig sein dass wir
bis zum herbst uns alle wirklich gut
durch impfen und auch die impfpflicht
weiter vorantreiben weil ich glaube
sonst wenn wir eine ähnliche szenario
leben wie wir das letzten herbst in dem
herbst davor auch schon erlebt haben wir
nehmen mit die zahlen sind zumindest die
kurzfristigen relativ klar die
perspektive ist es auch vielen dank
professor lehr dass sie das für uns
berechnet haben und ihr wissen mit uns
geteilt haben ende vorerst in sicht aber
nur wenn sich auch wirklich alle weiter
schützen und die zeit bis zum herbst
muss jetzt auch genutzt werden damit
dann nicht eine der nächsten kurve
quellen unser leben wieder übernimmt und
wieder bestimmt bis dahin aber
hoffentlich auch mal wieder zeit zum
krafttanken zum durchatmen zum frühling
genießen und auch den sommer auf bald
[Musik]